Shure: 大蒜都拿着吃
Shure: Just eat the garlic.
Shure: 肉不吃蒜香味少一半呢
Shure: Without garlic, the meat loses half its flavor.
Alice:你今天晚上想吃这个吗
Alice: Do you want to eat this tonight?
Alice:那我们打开吧
Alice: Then let's open it up.
Lucia: 可以吃好的
Lucia: Yeah, we can eat it, sure.
Alice:这个蜂蜜给你
Alice: Here's some honey for you.
Lucia: 哦你不你不用这个行
Lucia: Oh, you don't need this, right?
Jake:大师我们做什么呀
Jake: Master, what are we doing?
Alice:我不吃蜂蜜的
Alice: I don't eat honey.
Shure: 大师
Shure: Master.
Alice:大师你要蒜吗
Alice: Master, do you want garlic?
Shure: 不是别别
Shure: No, no.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 大师蒜拿生吃的
Shure: Master, garlic is eaten raw.
Tasha: 不要
Tasha: No.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 对然后把把生菜洗了吧
Shure: Yes, then let's wash the lettuce.
Shure: 来个人把生菜洗了
Shure: Someone wash the lettuce.
Lucia: 生吃大蒜
Lucia: Eating raw garlic.
Jake:生菜
Jake: Lettuce.
Shure: 没吃过吧
Shure: Haven't tried it, right?
Shure: 尝尝就知道了
Shure: Try it, you'll see.
Lucia: 可以生吃而且就是跟肉在一起
Lucia: You can eat it raw, and it's good with meat.
Tasha: 我知道了但
Tasha: I know, but...
Jake:怎么洗
Jake: How do we wash it?
Shure: 生生菜就是洗洗菜
Shure: Just wash the lettuce.
Lucia: 挺好吃的
Lucia: It's pretty good.
Lucia: 只不过就是吃完之后会有蒜味
Lucia: But you'll have garlic breath afterward.
Shure: 咋洗他咋洗知道不
Shure: Do you know how to wash it?
Shure: 拿个盆装里面
Shure: Put it in a basin.
Shure: 然后把生菜洗了
Shure: And then wash the lettuce.
Lucia: 所以一般很少这样
Lucia: So, it's not common.
Jake:干哈干哈干哈
Jake: What are we doing?
Jake:咱要干嘛
Shure: 就是把生菜洗
Shure: Just wash the lettuce.
Jake:洗洗生菜
Jake: Wash the lettuce.
Shure: 就剩生菜没洗了啊
Shure: Only the lettuce is left to wash.
Shure: 那个土豆
Shure: The potatoes...
Alice:生菜没洗
Alice: The lettuce isn't washed.
Shure: 土豆想吃的话就削了
Shure: If you want to eat potatoes, peel them.
Shure: 然后切成片
Shure: Then slice it up.
Alice:开开瓶
Alice: Open the bottle.
Jake:行啊
Jake: Sure.
Katrina: 好了麻烦你们起一下这个
Katrina: Alright, can you guys lift this?
Alice:我没有盆吗
Alice: Do I not have a bowl?
Jake:没有吧
Jake: No, I don't think so.
Jake:这锅怎么长这样这锅怎么长这样
Jake: Why does this pot look like this?
Alice:有人要纯酸奶吗
Alice: Does anyone want plain yogurt?
Alice:比较酸的
Alice: It's quite sour.
Jake:这锅为什么长成这个样子
Jake: Why does this pot look like this?
Jake:可以吃可以吃
Jake: It's edible, it's edible.
Lucia: 嗯那就3个
Lucia: Hmm, then three of them.
Alice:纯酸奶无糖的好
Alice: Plain yogurt without sugar is good.
Jake:嗯可以吃
Jake: Yeah, it's edible.
Tasha: 好没事
Tasha: Okay, no problem.
Lucia: 没事我可以把这个蜂蜜分享给你
Lucia: No worries, I can share this honey with you.
Alice:还有人吗还有人吗
Alice: Anyone else? Anyone else?
Lucia: 白砂糖也可以加
Lucia: You can also add white sugar.
Tasha: 其实还有人吗
Tasha: Actually, anyone else?
Alice:还有人吗
Alice: Anyone else?
Jake:好
Alice:微微你是纯酸奶吗
Alice: Tasha, do you want plain yogurt?
Jake:我给你清掉这个东西
Jake: I'll clear this thing for you.
Alice:那我们3个
Alice: Then the three of us.
Lucia: 行那我拿两个碗
Lucia: Alright, I'll get two bowls.
Lucia: 正好我刚洗完眉那个玩意
Lucia: I just finished washing that thing.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 这也没放油
Shure: There's no oil in this.
Shure: 想起来了
Shure: Just realized.
Jake:发生什么事
Jake: What happened?
Shure: 是吧是没放油吧再倒点
Shure: Right? There's no oil, add some more.
Shure: 你看看不行了吧
Shure: Look, it's not working, right?
Lucia: 我把我把手再冲一下去
Lucia: I'll rinse my hands again.
Alice:不放油也行吧
Alice: It's okay without oil, right?
Lucia: 我刚抓了那个生蚝袋子
Lucia: I just grabbed the oyster bag.
Shure: 不不行不行
Shure: No, no, it's not okay.
Shure: 得放下去
Shure: We need to add it.
Alice:你考的时候不是也要刷他吗
Alice: When you grill it, don't you brush it too?
Shure: 不刷不刷
Shure: No, don't brush.
Shure: 直接烤
Shure: Just grill directly.
Alice:不刷呦
Alice: No brushing
Jake:丢我嫌丢
Jake: Throw it away, I don't care
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah
Shure: 拿筷子别上手了
Shure: Use chopsticks, don't use your hands
Shure: 让你偷学
Shure: Let you secretly learn
Shure: 你都不学全了
Shure: You didn't learn everything
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 然后到时候出去骂教的不对退钱
Shure: And then when you go out, complain that you were taught wrong and ask for a refund
Katrina: 哈到时候出去别说我是修硕学生
Katrina: Haha, don't say you're Shure's student when you go out
Katrina: 我要放歌
Katrina: I want to play some music
Shure: 放吧把我电脑拿来吧
Shure: Go ahead, bring my computer
Shure: 进去拿就行
Shure: Just go in and get it
Shure: 应该没有你什么不能看的吧
Shure: There shouldn't be anything you can't see, right?
Shure: 闭着眼睛进去吧
Shure: Go in with your eyes closed
Shure: 哈哈哈有
Shure: Haha, just kidding, there is
Shure: 密码吗有
Shure: Password? Yes
Jake:黄丝球是我瞎还是不在这
Jake: Is the yellow ball here or not?
Lucia: 是好像是不在这
Lucia: Seems like it's not here
Jake:是我是是不在这OK
Jake: So it's not here, OK
Jake:总觉得我看到了又没看到
Jake: I feel like I saw it but didn't
Shure: 来
Shure: Come
Lucia: 你可能是看到了那个就是下水的那个
Lucia: Maybe you saw that thing for the drainage
Katrina: 就怎么用
Katrina: How to use it?
Katrina: 打开就行是吗
Katrina: Just open it, right?
Shure: 对这个就拧拧它的大小就好
Shure: Yes, just adjust its size
Jake:啊啊
Jake: Ah, ah
Shure: 随便放吧
Shure: Just place it anywhere
Katrina: 哦已经连上了哦
Katrina: Oh, it's already connected
Shure: 对已经连上
Shure: Yes, it's connected
Katrina: 只要直接插就行
Katrina: Just plug it in directly
Shure: 插上就行
Shure: Just plug it in
Tasha: 没有一个地方可以
Tasha: There's no place
Shure: 往里一点别掉
Shure: A little further in so it doesn't fall
Alice:嗯我给你
Alice: Hmm, I'll help you
Alice:这个芒果今天晚上要吃的
Alice: This mango is for eating tonight
Alice:这好像没有勺吧
Alice: Seems like there's no spoon
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oops, my bad
Alice:抱歉了
Alice: Sorry
Alice:用这个
Alice: Use this
Jake:我操哎呀
Jake: Damn, oh no
Jake:这东西怎么这
Jake: How does this thing...
Jake:能擦干净吗这
Jake: Can this be cleaned?
Tasha: 不能就算了
Tasha: If not, just forget it.
Alice:是不是有点抽象哈哈哈
Alice: Isn't it a bit abstract? Hahaha.
Tasha: 火吧
Tasha: Fire?
Alice:确实有点抽象
Alice: It really is a bit abstract.
Lucia: 这个不太好弄还是拿个那个
Lucia: This is kinda hard to handle, better get that thing.
Lucia: 中午啊今天中午外卖没给勺
Lucia: This noon, the takeout didn't come with a spoon.
Lucia: 其他的勺还有用吗
Lucia: Are the other spoons still available?
Lucia: 咱一会吃的时候得用勺
Lucia: We'll need to use a spoon when we eat later.
Lucia: 啊let me think
Lucia: Ah, let me think.
Lucia: 一次性餐具还有吗
Lucia: Do we still have any disposable utensils?
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Lucia: 一次那个一次性餐具
Lucia: Disposable utensils.
Lucia: 因为我们好像没什么勺
Lucia: Because we don't seem to have any spoons.
Lucia: 然后现在要舀这个
Lucia: And we need to scoop this now.
Alice:我用筷子弄的给你选一个吧
Alice: I'll use chopsticks, let me get one for you.
Jake:哦一次性勺啊
Jake: Oh, a disposable spoon.
Lucia: 随便都行
Lucia: Anything is fine.
Lucia: 但是但是
Lucia: But, but...
Lucia: 关键在于
Lucia: The key is...
Lucia: 咱们吃的时候要用勺吃
Lucia: We need to use a spoon when we eat.
Alice:我用筷子吧
Alice: I'll use chopsticks.
Jake:咱要不买一点吧
Jake: Why don't we buy some?
Jake:买个外卖买
Jake: Order some takeout and get...
Lucia: 嗯哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hmm, hahaha.
Jake:不是不是哈哈哈
Jake: No, no, hahaha.
Jake:就是外卖里面有配送这些商品的
Jake: I mean, takeout comes with these items.
Alice:给你选一个这
Alice: Let me pick one for you.
Jake:这这这有的选吗
Jake: Is there a choice?
Jake:这个左边
Jake: This one on the left.
Alice:不一样吗
Alice: Aren't they the same?
Tasha: 对啊他写上
Tasha: Yeah, he wrote on it.
Jake:对啊那选啥
Jake: Yeah, so what to choose?
Alice:差不多你随便选
Alice: Almost the same, pick any.
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Alice:这个给你放哪
Alice: Where should I put this for you?
Jake:给我放
Jake: Put it...
Tasha: 好了不用擦了洗不掉了
Tasha: Okay, no need to wipe it, it won't come off.
Tasha: 要把水沾到这个
Tasha: You need to get water on this.
Tasha: 沾到
Tasha: Got it
Lucia: 这个蜂蜜是一个勺型的
Lucia: This honey is scoopable.
Lucia: 所以我我可以用这个蜂蜜勺吃它
Lucia: So I can use this honey spoon to eat it.
Jake:我算洗完了吗
Jake: Am I done washing?
Tasha: 算现在要把它擦干
Tasha: Yeah, now you need to dry it.
Tasha: 就是就是
Tasha: Like this, just...
Tasha: 擦到看
Tasha: Wipe it until you see...
Alice:无油无水状态
Alice: No oil, no water.
Tasha: 啊这个明显还有水
Tasha: Ah, there's still water on it.
Tasha: 你要拿新的纸再擦一下
Tasha: You need to use a new paper towel to wipe it again.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:你尝一口吗
Jake: Do you want to try a bite?
Tasha: 嗯不尝
Tasha: Hmm, no thanks.
Shure: 来借个剪刀把碳打开
Shure: Can I borrow scissors to open the charcoal?
Tasha: OK啦
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 这包纸封在这就是专门擦他的
Tasha: This pack of paper towels is specifically for wiping it.
Jake:哦没看见多少
Jake: Oh, I didn't see much.
Jake:还是瞎了点
Jake: Still a bit blind.
Tasha: 底部就不用擦了里面
Tasha: You don't need to wipe the bottom, just the inside.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:爱擦就是要擦
Jake: If you love wiping, just wipe it.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This.
Shure: 来个帮我一起引碳的
Shure: Someone help me light the charcoal.
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Lucia: 我马上我把这个搅好
Lucia: I'll be right there, let me finish stirring this.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:不行
Jake: No.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This.
Jake:嘿嘿嘿对不起
Jake: Hehe, sorry.
Jake:7秒的记忆
Jake: 7-second memory.
Tasha: 人不如鱼系列
Tasha: Humans are worse than fish series.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Tasha: 好
Jake:锃光瓦亮是不
Jake: Shiny, isn't it?
Tasha: 嗯  干的好
Alice:是不是得给它弄开啊
Alice: Shouldn't we break it up?
Alice:这么大块不好点吧
Alice: It's too big to light, right?
Shure: 应该还行
Shure: It should be fine.
Katrina: YOLO目标检测模型
Katrina: YOLO target detection model.
Tasha: 鸡蛋呢
Tasha: Where's the egg?
Alice:不太好印
Alice: It's hard to stamp.
Alice:我拿点纸箱
Alice: Let me get some cardboard.
Tasha: 拿3个鸡蛋
Tasha: Grab three eggs.
Lucia: 我来我离得近
Lucia: I'll do it, I'm closer.
Tasha: 好那你来打吧
Tasha: Okay, you go ahead and crack them.
Alice:哦酒精棉是吗
Alice: Oh, is it alcohol wipes?
Lucia: 我害怕我会像那天那样打吗
Lucia: I'm scared I'll mess up like that day.
Lucia: 你你来打吧要不
Lucia: You do it instead, maybe?
Alice:干的
Alice: It's dry.
Lucia: 哦因为你戴着那个手套
Lucia: Oh, because you're wearing those gloves.
Shure: 像是硝酸那味
Shure: Smells like nitric acid.
Lucia: 但是我怕我不会打
Lucia: But I'm afraid I won't do it right.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Lucia: 就那天不是打错过一次
Lucia: Didn't I mess up once that day?
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a sec.
Tasha: 来吧
Tasha: Come on.
Tasha: 打这个碗里
Tasha: Crack them into this bowl.
Jake:好人类早期打蛋行为
Jake: Early human egg-cracking behavior.
Tasha: 不要碰到水
Tasha: Don't let it touch the water.
Tasha: 打滴滴滴滴
Tasha: Crack it bit by bit.
Tasha: 再滴再滴
Tasha: A bit more, a bit more.
Lucia: 就是小心蛋黄不能破
Lucia: Just be careful not to break the yolk.
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, amazing!
Lucia: 第一次就成功了
Lucia: Succeeded on the first try.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay!
Lucia: 要不还是你来吧
Lucia: Maybe you should do it instead.
Shure: 撕撕你这撕这么大干啥你说
Shure: Why are you tearing this so big, seriously?
Lucia: 哈哈哈我我拿着一个
Lucia: Haha, I'm holding one.
Jake:好看我的成功几个
Jake: Look at my successful ones.
Lucia: 你那个啥
Lucia: You know what...
Lucia: 这个要很小心的
Lucia: You need to be very careful with this.
Alice:这点够吗
Alice: Is this enough?
Shure: 够了够了
Shure: It's enough, it's enough.
Lucia: 我解决问题的方式回避问题
Lucia: My way of solving problems is to avoid them.
Jake:我来给你跟拍
Jake: I'll follow you with the camera.
Tasha: 把这个还是拿到楼上冰箱冷藏
Tasha: Take this upstairs to the fridge to chill.
Jake:没了
Jake: Done.
Lucia: 好的 10分钟吗
Lucia: Okay, 10 minutes?
Tasha: OK对
Tasha: OK, yeah.
Jake:那要不
Jake: So...
Tasha: 就等这边完事了
Tasha: Wait till we're done here.
Tasha: 那边就可以开始了
Tasha: Then we can start over there.
Lucia: 行好的
Lucia: Okay, got it.
Lucia: 算了还是放楼上吧
Lucia: Never mind, let's put it upstairs.
Katrina: 这可以吗
Katrina: Is this okay?
Katrina: 这可以也可以
Katrina: This is fine too.
Lucia: 要是放的话就得把这个架子调换一下，我看看楼上东西不多的情况下应该能放下
Shure: 我们最高度数的酒就是朗姆了
Shure: The strongest alcohol we have is rum.
Lucia: 最高度数的应该是咱楼上那个百家德
Lucia: The strongest one should be that Becherovka upstairs.
Shure: 那也不够烧的
Shure: That still won't burn.
Lucia: 这就先放楼下吧
Lucia: Let's just put this downstairs for now.
Lucia: 要不然楼上放不下了
Lucia: Otherwise, it won't fit upstairs.
Tasha: 暂时没有啦
Tasha: Not for now.
Lucia: 那我在旁边观摩
Lucia: Then I'll just watch from the side.
Alice:我姐拿个炭过去烧吧
Alice: My sister can take some charcoal over and burn it.
Tasha: 呃好
Tasha: Uh, okay.
Jake:也也也对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, right.
Tasha: 有任何需要搭把手的
Tasha: If you need any help, just let me know.
Jake:是大成功吗
Jake: Is it a big success?
Lucia: 今天是要做什么呢
Lucia: What are we doing today?
Shure: 应该成功了点
Shure: It should be a bit successful.
Jake:应该成功
Jake: It should be successful.
Tasha: 呃伯爵红茶
Tasha: Uh, Earl Grey tea.
Tasha: 芒果再搞点芒果吧
Tasha: Let's get some more mangoes.
Shure: 刚才那夹呢
Shure: Where's the clip from before?
Katrina: 哇那个我们学校卖可贵了
Katrina: Wow, it's so expensive at our school.
Tasha: 注意下注意下注意
Tasha: Be careful, be careful, be careful.
Shure: 夹去哪了
Shure: Where did the clip go?
Tasha: 哦多了再煮一会
Tasha: Oh, boil it a bit longer.
Tasha: 嗯真的
Tasha: Hmm, really.
Jake:真的真的吼吼
Jake: Really, really, ha ha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈笑死我了
Alice: Hahaha, this is killing me.
Jake:我看看你的小本本
Jake: Let me see your little notebook.
Shure: 哎倒也行你别说
Shure: Hey, it's actually not bad, don't you think?
Jake:红茶包红茶包
Jake: Earl Grey tea bags, Earl Grey tea bags.
Jake:哪来的买的
Jake: Where did you get them from?
Tasha: 买的
Tasha: Bought them.
Tasha: 你觉得哪来的
Tasha: Where do you think?
Jake:买的
Jake: Bought them.
Alice:是不是就是这样的
Alice: Is it just like this?
Shure: 卧槽好像是
Shure: Whoa, it seems like it.
Shure: 好像是哎
Shure: It really seems like it.
Tasha: 林涵好聪明
Tasha: Lin Han is so smart.
Shure: 哦对
Shure: Oh yeah.
Shure: 他放在底下卧槽
Shure: He put it at the bottom, damn.
Jake:加3T蛋黄
Jake: Add 3 tablespoons of egg yolk.
Tasha: 3个吧
Tasha: Make it 3.
Shure: 加大火势
Shure: Increase the heat.
Katrina: 这个这个东西好用吗
Katrina: Is this thing any good?
Jake:分两次筛入低筋面粉 0.5包
Jake: Sift in half a pack of low-gluten flour in two batches.
Shure: 来给我都给他烧了
Shure: Come on, burn it all for him.
Jake:茶包30克
Jake: 30 grams of tea bags.
Jake:奶茶23克
Jake: 23 grams of milk tea.
Jake:植物油护油脂哦
Jake: Use vegetable oil to protect the fat.
Alice:晚上玩火会怎么尿床
Alice: Playing with fire at night will make you wet the bed.
Katrina: 尿床
Katrina: Wet the bed.
Shure: 尿炕
Shure: Wet the bed.
Lucia: 哇这是什么味道
Lucia: Wow, what's that smell?
Katrina: 是楼下那个烧炭火的
Katrina: It's from the charcoal burning downstairs.
Tasha: 怎么还是这么多呢
Tasha: Why is there still so much?
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:要把它蒸发掉是吗
Jake: Do we need to evaporate it?
Tasha: 嗯对就是浓缩到一定的比例
Tasha: Yeah, just concentrate it to a certain ratio.
Jake:嗯咋没写
Jake: Hmm, why isn't it written?
Tasha: 咋没写
Tasha: Why isn't it written?
Jake:没写嗯
Jake: It's not written, hmm.
Jake:是哪一个呀
Jake: Which one is it?
Shure: 但说实话有点不够
Shure: But to be honest, it's a bit lacking.
Lucia: 嗯这都还有水不知道大家还喝不喝
Lucia: Yeah, there's still water here, I don't know if anyone will drink it.
Tasha: 这呢
Tasha: How about this?
Jake:在哪呢 30克
Jake: Where is it? 30 grams.
Shure: 但没有关系
Shure: But it's okay.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:嗯哦
Jake: Hmm, oh.
Katrina: 什么东西
Katrina: What's that?
Lucia: 早晨的这个水要倒掉
Lucia: The water from the morning needs to be poured out.
Jake:80毫升的牛奶给运煮到30克是吗
Jake: Boil 80 milliliters of milk down to 30 grams, right?
Lucia: 这个这个应该是新杯哎
Lucia: This should be a new cup, hey.
Shure: 都快着了吧
Shure: It's almost burning.
Lucia: 这这几个呢
Lucia: What about these?
Katrina: 行啊
Katrina: Sure.
Tasha: 对就是要把它们浓缩掉
Tasha: Yeah, just concentrate them.
Jake:那明白了
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 我感觉没有
Lucia: I don't think so.
Jake:明白
Jake: Understood.
Shure: 哎对
Lucia: 这应该也是新杯子
Lucia: This should be a new cup too.
Jake:炼乳是这种东西吗
Jake: Is this what condensed milk looks like?
Lucia: 嗯感觉可以
Lucia: Hmm, seems fine.
Lucia: 因为我们一会如果要倒饮料就可以倒
Lucia: Because if we need to pour drinks later, we can use it.
Tasha: 炼乳是什么东西
Tasha: What is condensed milk?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 就是你常吃的炼乳
Tasha: It's the condensed milk you usually eat.
Lucia: 剩下这些是大家用过的
Lucia: The rest of these have been used by everyone.
Jake:对是是这么念出来的吗
Jake: Yeah, is that how you pronounce it?
Tasha: 是这么炼的
Tasha: That's how you condense it.
Jake:就是就是是
Jake: Yes, yes, that's it.
Jake:炼乳啊那个
Jake: Condensed milk, that stuff.
Shure: 火化炉是不是不够了加
Shure: Is the crematorium running out of fuel?
Jake:那种很甜的那种酱你知道吧
Jake: That very sweet sauce, you know?
Tasha: 啊对就是那个
Tasha: Ah, yes, that's it.
Lucia: 算了不关
Lucia: Never mind, don't worry about it.
Jake:就就就是这种就这么整烧出来的吗
Jake: So, you just burn it like this to make it?
Tasha: 就是这么烧出来的
Tasha: Yes, that's how you make it.
Shure: 非常符合我们的环保理念
Shure: It aligns perfectly with our environmental concept.
Tasha: 呃好可以是
Tasha: Uh, okay, sure.
Shure: 就哭哭烧
Shure: Just burn it to ashes.
Shure: 这烫不烫
Shure: Is it hot?
Tasha: 完了又少了
Tasha: Oh no, it's less again.
Jake:那咋办
Jake: What should we do?
Tasha: 少了没有办法
Tasha: If it's less, there's nothing we can do.
Tasha: 味道浓一些
Tasha: The flavor will be stronger.
Shure: 别给他盖聂了
Shure: Don't cover it with the lid.
Shure: 不能吧应该
Shure: You can't, can you?
Alice:收起来
Alice: Put it away.
Jake:你上回说的你要搞
Jake: Last time you said you wanted to do it.
Jake:几个这种彩票款
Jake: A few of these lottery tickets.
Shure: 我操
Shure: Damn.
Alice:这是可以录的吗
Alice: Can this be recorded?
Jake:你不是说想搞几个彩票款
Jake: Didn't you say you wanted to do a few lottery tickets?
Jake:彩票款吗
Jake: Lottery tickets?
Jake:看谁能吃到
Jake: Let's see who can get it.
Tasha: 算了呃那个打蛋器呃盆
Tasha: Never mind, um, the whisk, um, the bowl.
Tasha: 对就是那个盆啊
Tasha: Yeah, that bowl.
Lucia: 呃上次用的那个
Lucia: Uh, the one we used last time.
Tasha: 就是你刚冷冻起来的那个
Tasha: The one you just froze.
Shure: 应该
Shure: Should be.
Lucia: 哦get it
Lucia: Oh, got it.
Shure: 都着了吧这碳
Shure: All the charcoal is lit, right?
Tasha: 哎还有一个呢
Tasha: Hey, there's another one.
Shure: 还没着吗
Shure: It's not lit yet?
Alice:没反应呢
Alice: No reaction yet.
Katrina: 对对对明天买
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, buy it tomorrow.
Shure: 这还是那半家烧的
Shure: This is still that half-burned.
Tasha: 少了一个这个
Tasha: Missing one of these.
Katrina: 明天买下美文纸和旺仔牛
Katrina: Buy the beautiful paper and Wangzai milk tomorrow.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:做做早饭
Jake: Make breakfast.
Lucia: 哎奇怪我找找看
Lucia: Hey, weird, I'll look for it.
Katrina: yes
Katrina: Yes.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:这火还没那个
Alice: The fire hasn't, uh...
Lucia: 嗯有没有可能
Lucia: Hmm, is it possible...
Shure: 一根一根烧
Shure: Burn one by one.
Katrina: 几天我想想
Katrina: A few days, let me think.
Jake:等快递整整理整理
Jake: Wait for the delivery, then sort it out.
Shure: 其实最快的方法就是加酒精
Shure: Actually, the fastest way is to add alcohol.
Katrina: 那今天晚上就
Katrina: So tonight...
Katrina: 明天必须压了
Katrina: It must be pressed tomorrow.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Katrina: 那我等会压一下
Katrina: Then I'll press it later.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Lucia: 楼家要是没有我就再上楼看一下
Lucia: If there's none downstairs, I'll check upstairs again.
Shure: 最快的方法就是加酒精啊
Shure: The fastest way is to add alcohol.
Katrina: 时间过得可真快
Katrina: Time really flies.
Jake:是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 嗯啊好的
Lucia: Hmm, alright.
Alice:讲什么没听清
Alice: What are you talking about? I couldn't hear clearly.
Jake:划划水就划完了
Jake: Just paddling and it's all over.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Jake:特别
Jake: Especially.
Alice:给这摊上喷点油
Alice: Spray some oil on this.
Alice:让他烧着
Alice: Let it burn.
Shure: 你给他又加回来的是吗
Shure: Did you put it back again?
Shure: 还是说他一直在这呢
Shure: Or has it been here all the time?
Alice:没他就在这上边呢
Alice: No, it's been up here.
Jake:刷不完吗
Jake: Can't it be cleaned off?
Jake:烧烧 不起来吗
Jake: Burn it, won't it light up?
Lucia: 总感觉这勺子可以留一下
Lucia: I feel like we can keep this spoon.
Alice:这探看起来也就受了点皮外伤
Alice: This probe seems to only have a minor scratch.
Tasha: 你能帮我一下吗
Tasha: Can you help me out?
Lucia: 要不放旁边吧
Lucia: Maybe put it aside?
Shure: 确实没浇透
Shure: It's indeed not soaked through.
Jake:哦要大酒精
Jake: Oh, we need stronger alcohol.
Tasha: 可以帮我一下吗
Tasha: Can you help me out?
Jake:那给你买一个呗
Jake: Then I'll buy you one.
Lucia: 嗯你说
Lucia: Yeah, go ahead.
Jake:让他4020分钟再到
Jake: Have it delivered in 20 minutes.
Jake:40分钟再到
Jake: 40 minutes at most.
Shure: 就最快最快的酒精
Shure: The fastest alcohol available.
Shure: 你就搜酒精
Shure: Just search for alcohol.
Shure: 然后最好20分钟就能到那种
Shure: Ideally, it should arrive in 20 minutes.
Jake:好行
Jake: Okay, got it.
Tasha: 加75克糖
Tasha: Add 75 grams of sugar.
Shure: 或者买药那块
Shure: Or buy it from the pharmacy.
Shure: 最快的应该
Shure: That should be the fastest.
Tasha: and 0.5的茶
Tasha: And 0.5 grams of tea.
Tasha: 3个蛋黄
Tasha: 3 egg yolks.
Lucia: 这个碗里没有油就是好洗
Lucia: This bowl is easy to clean since there's no oil.
Shure: 综合排序
Shure: Sort by overall ranking.
Tasha: 75克柠檬
Tasha: 75 grams of lemon.
Shure: 速度优先
Shure: Prioritize speed.
Tasha: 好了吗哦
Tasha: Is it ready?
Lucia: 还没好
Lucia: Not yet.
Lucia: 是75克吗
Lucia: Is it 75 grams?
Tasha: 先到20 呃先到21.7
Tasha: First to 20, uh, first to 21.7.
Lucia: 现在21.7克
Lucia: It's now 21.7 grams.
Tasha: 呃因为我要先加
Tasha: Uh, because I need to add first.
Lucia: 再来一点
Lucia: Add a bit more.
Tasha: 低呃算了
Tasha: Low, uh, never mind.
Tasha: 快到吧
Tasha: Almost there.
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: Done.
Tasha: 这是不是有点太小了
Tasha: Isn't this a bit too small?
Lucia: 有可能我们要不倒多少
Lucia: Maybe we shouldn't pour too much.
Tasha: 分两次
Tasha: Do it in two times.
Lucia: 然后取对取下来再那个什么
Lucia: Then take it off and then...
Lucia: 你是刚好要加两次吗
Lucia: Are you going to add it twice?
Tasha: 我要加三次
Tasha: I'm going to add it three times.
Tasha: 那你倒35克先
Tasha: So you pour 35 grams first.
Tasha: 然后剩下的你再倒35
Tasha: Then pour another 35 grams with the rest.
Lucia: 要在这里面
Lucia: Is it in here?
Lucia: 在在家吗
Lucia: Inside the house?
Jake:其实还行吧
Jake: Actually, it's fine.
Jake:他说8:50就到了
Jake: He said he'll be here at 8:50.
Alice:我刚才是应该是
Alice: Just now I was...
Lucia: 刚才是35
Lucia: Just now it was 35.
Tasha: 三十五
Tasha: Thirty-five.
Lucia: 那这个这个是要到多少
Lucia: So how much should this be?
Katrina: 那这个这个啊
Katrina: So this, this...
Tasha: 四十啊
Tasha: Forty.
Jake:谢文柱咱吃的到
Jake: We'll be able to eat.
Lucia: 直接到40啊
Lucia: Just pour it up to 40.
Shure: 心如过来今晚上
Shure: Xinru is coming tonight.
Jake:他说他过
Jake: He said he's coming.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Shure: 放放这边
Shure: Put it here.
Jake:我也要玩啊
Jake: I want to play too.
Lucia: 40克
Lucia: 40 grams.
Jake:打发是吧
Jake: Whipped, right?
Tasha: 好你来
Tasha: Okay, you do it.
Jake:好你从哪找这样的
Jake: Where did you find this?
Lucia: 26.8
Lucia: 26.8.
Jake:另一个啊
Jake: The other one.
Jake:另一个那个
Jake:哎少在这小的
Jake: Hey, let's use the smaller one.
Tasha: 你猜
Tasha: Guess.
Lucia: 29.9
Lucia: 29.9.
Jake:凑30是吗
Jake: Round it up to 30, right?
Tasha: 40啊
Tasha: Forty.
Lucia: 40差不多
Lucia: 40 is about right.
Shure: 我觉得这样就可以
Shure: I think this is fine.
Tasha: 好差不多来
Tasha: Okay, that's about right.
Lucia: 外面那点不管他
Lucia: Don't worry about the outside
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 全弄着有希望了
Shure: It looks promising now
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:这么多数字我用几
Jake: With so many numbers, which one should I use?
Shure: 还好今天风是往那边刮
Shure: Fortunately, the wind is blowing that way today
Shure: 不然呼呼全刮家里了
Shure: Otherwise, it would blow everything into the house
Tasha: 拉到最大就行哎呦
Tasha: Just pull it to the max, that’s all
Jake:哈哈哈你不是说拉到最大就行
Jake: Hahaha, didn't you say just pull it to the max?
Lucia: 哈哈哈你猜
Lucia: Hahaha, you guess
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Tasha: 好好来吧
Tasha: Alright, come on
Shure: 也是是哪个倒没
Shure: Which one is it?
Tasha: 是
Tasha: Yes
Lucia: 我
Lucia: Me
Shure: 咱开窗我能告诉他关上吗
Shure: Can I tell him to close the window if we open it?
Lucia: 你猜我那天裤子上奶油是怎么奔上的
Lucia: Guess how the cream ended up on my pants that day
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Haha
Tasha: 来吧
Tasha: Come on
Shure: 啊那是那谁
Shure: Ah, that was who?
Jake:有点突然
Jake: A bit sudden
Tasha: 雨露均沾一下
Tasha: Let’s share the love
Alice:没事风没往那边吹
Alice: It's fine, the wind isn’t blowing that way
Jake:好哎好玩
Jake: Okay, it's fun
Shure: 雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
Shure: 雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan
Shure: 你是不是住这个楼上
Shure: Do you live upstairs?
Shure: 就是阳阁楼上
Shure: I mean the sunny attic
Shure: 你把那个窗户关上
Shure: Can you close that window?
Katrina: 窗户关上
Katrina: Close the window
Katrina: OK
Shure: 感觉这次应该可以
Shure: I feel like it should work this time
Shure: 都找进来了
Shure: Everything is in place
Shure: 这算找下来吗
Shure: Does this count as finding it?
Shure: 这没算找下来
Shure: This doesn’t count as finding it
Jake:是这么回事吧
Jake: Is that how it works?
Tasha: 停了加最后一次糖吧
Tasha: Stop, let’s add the last bit of sugar
Lucia: 我不知道要问威威
Lucia: I don't know, ask Weiwei
Tasha: 加最后一次糖
Tasha: Add the last bit of sugar
Lucia: 谁
Lucia: Who?
Tasha: 停停加最后一次糖
Tasha: Stop, stop, add the sugar one last time.
Shure: 不行啊
Shure: No way.
Alice:用大块碳爆炸
Alice: Use the big chunk of coal to explode.
Tasha: 你看呃要
Tasha: Look, um, you need to...
Tasha: 嗯嗯行没事
Tasha: Hmm, okay, it's fine.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 到现在还就那一块呢
Shure: Up to now, it's still that one piece.
Shure: 是不
Shure: Right?
Tasha: 叫
Tasha: Call.
Shure: 他别灭了
Shure: Don't let him put it out.
Shure: 他他妈还灭了
Shure: Damn, he put it out.
Lucia: 我把这掉出来这糖稍微清一下
Lucia: I'll take this out, clean the sugar a bit.
Lucia: 这个应该我有点不敢靠近你哈哈哈
Lucia: I should, I'm a bit scared to get close to you, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 这个应该没用了
Lucia: This should be useless now.
Lucia: 酸奶都吃完了
Lucia: The yogurt is all gone.
Jake:他为什么能打起来啊
Jake: Why can he make it work?
Tasha: 他他把空气给抽出去了
Tasha: He, he sucked out the air.
Shure: 别一会酒精来了我们火没了
Shure: Don't let the alcohol come, or our fire will go out.
Tasha: 然后他就会膨胀
Tasha: Then it will expand.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Alice:不是没有这个可能
Alice: It's not impossible.
Tasha: 好停一下
Tasha: Alright, stop for a moment.
Tasha: 嗯你看停到什么样的程度
Tasha: Hmm, see to what extent it has stopped.
Tasha: 就你你这样子拉他他就立起来了就行
Tasha: Just like this, if you pull it, it will stand up, that's fine.
Tasha: 东西有点太多了哦哎
Tasha: There are a bit too many things, oh hey.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 不要再打了
Tasha: Don't hit it anymore.
Tasha: 好了好了下场
Tasha: Alright, alright, next round.
Jake:我不用打了
Jake: I don't need to hit it anymore.
Jake:下场下场就拿走洗掉
Jake: Next round, next round, just take it away and wash it off.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Tasha: 对把它拔下来洗了就行
Tasha: Yes, just pull it off and wash it, that will do.
Jake:对好的
Jake: Yes, okay.
Tasha: 有点打的过了
Tasha: Hit it a bit too much.
Shure: 你都没放孜
Shure: You didn't even add cumin.
Jake:这个是挺
Jake: This is pretty...
Jake:什么什么叫打过啊
Jake: What do you mean by 'beaten'?
Jake:这还能打过呢
Jake: Can this even be beaten?
Jake:太硬了
Jake: It's too tough.
Jake:哦没关系
Jake: Oh, it's okay.
Tasha: 加85克这个这个嗯
Tasha: Add 85 grams of this, um...
Shure: 油放了蚝油也放了
Shure: Added oil and oyster sauce.
Jake:排练一下
Jake: Let's rehearse.
Jake:最后一天我好好打
Jake: I'll give my best on the last day.
Shure: 但酱油没有
Shure: But no soy sauce.
Lucia: 85克呃这个这是什么呀
Lucia: 85 grams of, uh, what is this?
Shure: 酱油我以为不用放
Shure: I thought we didn't need soy sauce.
Tasha: 你可以先倒40克
Tasha: You can pour 40 grams first.
Shure: 完了
Shure: It's done.
Lucia: 低筋粉好的
Lucia: Low-gluten flour, got it.
Tasha: 然后再加45克
Tasha: Then add another 45 grams.
Shure: 到老到老少整一样啊
Shure: Same amount for both old and young.
Tasha: 但感觉这个是不是有点小
Tasha: But doesn't this seem a bit small?
Lucia: 这个碗是吗
Lucia: This bowl, right?
Tasha: 容器有点太小了
Tasha: The container is a bit too small.
Lucia: 哈哈哈试试看先 4045
Lucia: Haha, let's try first. 40-45.
Lucia: 可能有点
Lucia: It might be a bit...
Tasha: 我感觉这个
Tasha: I feel like this...
Lucia: 这个这
Lucia: This, this...
Tasha: 这个小碗倒30克可能就差不多
Tasha: This small bowl, 30 grams should be enough.
Tasha: 好那就那就30克吧
Tasha: Okay, let's go with 30 grams then.
Tasha: 那加3次要加85克
Tasha: So, we need to add 85 grams in three times.
Shure: 香香
Shure: Smells good.
Lucia: 行稍等二九点啊
Lucia: Okay, hold on a second.
Shure: 虽然还没吃上
Shure: Even though we haven't tasted it yet.
Shure: 但拌起来闻着就很香
Shure: But it smells great while mixing.
Lucia: 再来一点
Lucia: Add a bit more.
Lucia: 耶刚好
Lucia: Yay, just right.
Shure: 我妈远程通过看我
Shure: My mom is watching me remotely.
Tasha: 茶包
Tasha: Tea bag.
Shure: 这晌告诉我什么放的少了
Shure: She's telling me if I missed anything.
Katrina: 你妈这能看出来
Katrina: Your mom can see that?
Jake:啥
Jake: What?
Katrina: 你刚那平板的充电宝呢
Katrina: Where's the charger for the tablet?
Shure: 我跟我妈
Shure: I was talking to my mom.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Jake:哦哦哦你妈给你指导的是吧
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, your mom is guiding you, right?
Lucia: 第二回放多少 20还是25
Lucia: For the second round, how much? 20 or 25?
Shure: 对远程指导
Shure: Yeah, remote guidance.
Jake:哦可以可以
Jake: Oh, got it, got it.
Jake:为了不断为了不止于羞辱
Jake: To avoid continuous humiliation.
Tasha: 都可以只要最后一共是85就行
Tasha: Anything's fine as long as it totals 85 in the end.
Lucia: 一共85 刚才30啊
Lucia: Total 85. We had 30 just now.
Shure: 那个呢
Shure: And what about that?
Jake:能放油吗
Jake: Can we add oil?
Lucia: 那还差50
Lucia: Then we need 50 more.
Jake:你这个火
Jake: Your fire...
Lucia: 那就那就2525行吗
Lucia: How about 25, 25? Is that okay?
Shure: 油肯定不能放吧
Shure: We definitely can't add oil, right?
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: We can.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Okay then.
Jake:助然嘛
Jake: Naturally.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then...
Katrina: 你妈说烧烤粉放少了
Katrina: Your mom said you added too little barbecue powder.
Alice:什么这么呛
Alice: Why is it so smoky?
Shure: 他说好看着
Shure: He said, watch carefully.
Shure: 因为正常好像他说是要放酱油的
Shure: Because normally, he said we need to add soy sauce.
Shure: 但是我忘记有这个
Shure: But I forgot about that.
Shure: 对然后就是靠酱油带带
Shure: Yeah, so we rely on soy sauce to...
Jake:那就那还能
Jake: Then, can we still...
Jake:还能救吗
Jake: Can we still save it?
Shure: 不是一个是带色
Shure: One is for color.
Shure: 再一个就是咸味嘛
Shure: Another is for the salty taste.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 那就补补点这个呗
Shure: So let's just add a bit of that.
Jake:补点吧可以
Jake: Add a bit, sure.
Lucia: 24.9
Lucia: 24.9.
Jake:来上酱油
Jake: Come on, add the soy sauce.
Shure: 酱油没有
Shure: There's no soy sauce.
Shure: 咱们我以为不用
Shure: I thought we didn't need it.
Shure: 所以我就没买你知道吗
Shure: So I didn't buy it, you know?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:那咋办呢放点盐
Jake: Then what do we do? Add some salt?
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: No worries, no worries.
Shure: 就是缺缺这个
Shure: It's just missing that.
Shure: 就补了点烧烤料就差不多
Shure: Just added some barbecue seasoning, should be about right.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then...
Jake:低配版问题不大
Jake: The low-end version isn't a big deal.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Jake:为最后一天准备是吧
Jake: Preparing for the last day, right?
Shure: 80%还原了已经
Shure: It's already 80% restored.
Shure: 货不货
Shure: Goods or not?
Lucia: 24.8行吗差的不OK
Lucia: Is 24.8 okay? If not, then not okay.
Shure: 还有那个
Shure: And that...
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Lucia: 哇这个低筋粉用的还蛮快的咦哈哈
Lucia: Wow, this low-gluten flour is being used up fast, haha.
Shure: 那个一会记得也呼了一下
Shure: Remember to call that one later.
Shure: 我再去看外面看看火
Shure: I'll go check the fire outside.
Shure: 好火彻底灭了
Shure: Alright, the fire is completely out.
Shure: 哦你问问管家
Shure: Oh, ask the butler.
Jake:一点火星都不剩
Jake: Not a single spark left.
Shure: 管家能不能帮忙送个酒精啥的
Shure: Can the butler help bring some alcohol or something?
Shure: 应该有你快问一下酒精啥的
Shure: There should be some, quickly ask for alcohol or something.
Shure: 反正最后一天也得用
Shure: Anyway, we'll need it on the last day too.
Shure: 你问问管家有没有酒精
Shure: Ask the butler if there's any alcohol.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 那个到哪了瞅一眼
Shure: Where did it go? Take a look.
Shure: 点一下完成
Shure: Click to complete it.
Shure: OK 9分钟39就能吃上了
Shure: OK, in 9 minutes and 39 seconds we can eat.
Shure: 能吃上吧
Shure: Can we eat?
Lucia: 烤的时间比较久是吗
Lucia: It takes a long time to bake, right?
Lucia: 哇这个这个
Lucia: Wow, this, this...
Lucia: 好像我爸每次炒的牛肉
Lucia: Looks like the beef my dad fries every time.
Lucia: 他就会拌成这样
Lucia: He always mixes it like this.
Lucia: 非常非常像
Lucia: Very, very similar.
Tasha: 茶包哎
Tasha: Tea bag, eh?
Tasha: 我刚拿了吗
Tasha: Did I just get it?
Lucia: 饿了哈哈哈饿了
Lucia: Hungry, haha, I'm hungry.
Alice:好想下手抓一抓
Alice: Really want to grab it.
Tasha: 然后加哦
Tasha: Then add, oh.
Tasha: 植物油植物油
Tasha: Vegetable oil, vegetable oil.
Tasha: 哎哎这呢
Tasha: Ah, here it is.
Jake:这叫伯爵奶茶是吗
Jake: This is called Earl Grey milk tea, right?
Tasha: 油呢油呢哎油呢
Tasha: Where's the oil, where's the oil, ah, where's the oil?
Tasha: 哎这谁拿到这的
Tasha: Hey, who put this here?
Alice:每件浅色衣服都逃不过
Alice: No light-colored clothes can escape this.
Shure: 拿点
Shure: Get some.
Tasha: 好能把搅一下吗
Tasha: Can you stir it?
Tasha: 就是拿筷子搅一下
Tasha: Just stir it with chopsticks.
Shure: 厨房湿巾在哪
Shure: Where are the kitchen wipes?
Shure: 楼上吗
Shure: Upstairs?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Lucia: 是要大概搅到啥程度呀
Lucia: How much should we stir it?
Tasha: 融合就行
Tasha: Until it's mixed.
Tasha: 没关系这里面还会再融的
Tasha: It's fine, it'll mix more inside.
Lucia: 啊这俩要要要融合可能要
Lucia: Ah, for these two to mix, it might take...
Shure: 把那个一会烤架给擦一下
Shure: Wipe down the grill in a bit.
Jake:这好融啊
Jake: This melts well.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright.
Lucia: 哈哈先把牛顿
Lucia: Haha, first let's get Newton.
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么融化
Jake: Hahaha, how does this melt?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 但是这个这个原理是牛顿发现的
Lucia: But this, this principle was discovered by Newton.
Jake:不管他不管不管
Jake: Whatever, whatever.
Lucia: 不管他反正对
Lucia: Doesn't matter, anyway.
Jake:反正物理有物理的问题
Jake: Physics has its own issues.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 生物学有关的问题都归到牛顿头上
Lucia: All biological problems are attributed to Newton.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 就脚就行了
Tasha: Just stir it.
Alice:擦完之后是不是还得洗
Alice: After wiping, should we wash it?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Alice:这上面可是洗洁精之类的那种东西
Alice: There's dish soap or something on it.
Tasha: 因为会打过
Tasha: Because we'll use it.
Alice:你却也能吃肚子里
Alice: You might end up eating it.
Shure: 拿这个过来一下
Shure: Bring this over here.
Tasha: 应该没有问题了
Tasha: It should be fine.
Jake:那为什么不能用他的那个一
Jake: Then why not use that one...
Shure: 没问题真的
Shure: No problem, really.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Alice:要不洗一下吧
Alice: How about we wash it?
Jake:他不是有好几档吗
Jake: Doesn't he have several settings?
Shure: 方便的话就冲一下
Shure: If it's convenient, rinse it.
Tasha: 是的你真的很聪明
Tasha: Yes, you're really smart.
Shure: 因为这个基本就是干净的啊
Shure: Because this is basically clean.
Tasha: 要不你来
Tasha: How about you do it?
Shure: 确实稍微冲一下
Shure: Just give it a slight rinse.
Tasha: 哎呀
Tasha: Oh no.
Shure: 谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Shure: 已经饿的不行了是吗哈哈
Shure: You're starving, aren't you? Haha.
Tasha: 这是切蛋糕
Tasha: This is for cutting the cake.
Tasha: 的
Tasha: Yeah.
Shure: 卧槽有的着了居然有两块红了已经
Shure: Wow, some of it is burnt, and two pieces are already red.
Alice:大的小的
Alice: Big pieces or small?
Shure: 大的
Shure: Big ones.
Alice:牛逼
Alice: Awesome.
Jake:这是切蛋糕的
Jake: This is for cutting the cake.
Lucia: 呃对那天微微解释一下他怎么用的
Lucia: Uh, right, that day Tasha explained how to use it.
Lucia: 但是其实我也没搞明白
Lucia: But I still didn't quite get it.
Lucia: 反正总之就是这样用的
Lucia: Anyway, this is how you use it.
Jake:什么时候切
Jake: When do we cut it?
Tasha: 等会就切
Tasha: We'll cut it in a bit.
Tasha: 你要切吗
Tasha: Do you want to cut it?
Jake:我要切
Jake: I want to cut it.
Tasha: 好你切
Tasha: Okay, you cut it.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake:我想象不出来
Jake: I can't imagine.
Jake:一点都想象不出来
Jake: I really can't imagine.
Tasha: 你能帮我扶一下
Tasha: Can you hold this for me?
Tasha: 从这开始
Tasha: Start from here.
Lucia: 这个大概搅成什么样呀
Lucia: How should we mix this?
Tasha: 就这样就行了
Tasha: Just like this is fine.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 只不过我这边还在压模具
Tasha: But I'm still pressing the mold over here.
Lucia: 嗯那我趁你压的时候接着搅搅
Lucia: Okay, I'll keep mixing while you press.
Shure: 那是哪个我再找找
Shure: Which one is it? I'll look again.
Tasha: 压的不好看
Tasha: The pressing doesn't look good.
Tasha: 不过没关系
Tasha: But it's okay.
Tasha: 我不想认真叠它了就这样
Tasha: I don't want to stack it nicely, just like this.
Alice:我的边边呢
Alice: Where's my piece?
Tasha: 什么你来好了呀
Tasha: What, you should just do it.
Alice:like that
Alice: Like that.
Tasha: 要越高越好
Tasha: The higher the better.
Tasha: 因为这样子可以减少它的气泡
Tasha: Because this way, it can reduce its bubbles.
Tasha: 据说是这样子
Tasha: That's what they say.
Tasha: 不知道做了几个人的量
Tasha: Not sure how many people this will serve.
Alice:玩不上
Alice: Can't play.
Shure: 我是周一回来
Shure: I'll be back on Monday.
Jake:这就整完了
Jake: It's all done.
Jake:就剩烤了
Jake: Just need to bake it.
Shure: 周日最后一天
Shure: Sunday is the last day.
Shure: 但这地好像租个周几我忘了
Shure: But I can't remember which day we rented this place for.
Shure: 你周日可以来来吃吃喝喝玩玩
Shure: You can come on Sunday to eat, drink, and have fun.
Shure: 不你周日如果不去的话你就要来
Shure: If you don't go on Sunday, you have to come.
Shure: 因为我已经添上你的名字了
Shure: Because I've already added your name.
Jake:这是预热过的
Jake: This is preheated.
Jake:烤40分钟
Jake: Bake for 40 minutes.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:就等着就行了嗯
Jake: Just wait, that's it.
Tasha: 然后再打发个奶油就行
Tasha: And then whip some cream.
Tasha: 但是奶油打发等它快烤出来再打就行
Tasha: But whip the cream when it's almost done baking.
Shure: 咱们最后一天是周一还是周日来着
Shure: So is our last day Monday or Sunday?
Jake:周日哎
Jake: Sunday.
Jake:周周一周日搞完活动周一
Jake: Wrap up on Sunday, and on Monday...
Jake:呃划划水
Jake: Uh, just relax.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Jake:复个盘拆屋子
Jake: Review and take down the setup.
Tasha: 我们结束了
Tasha: We're done.
Jake:把屋子拆了
Jake: Take down the setup.
Tasha: 这个还要小
Tasha: This one still needs to be smaller.
Tasha: 没事了
Tasha: It's fine.
Tasha: 这个洗了等会打奶油用
Tasha: This one is washed and ready for whipping cream.
Lucia: 打奶
Lucia: Whip the cream.
Alice:打奶油
Alice: Whip the cream.
Tasha: 现在开始哎
Tasha: Starting now, hey.
Shure: 这个油肯定不行
Shure: This oil won't work.
Shure: 你还有汽油啊
Shure: Do you have gasoline?
Jake:我们没有汽油但是可以
Jake: We don't have gasoline, but we can...
Shure: 哈哈哈他有两块
Shure: Haha, he has two pieces.
Shure: 着了汽油你可以倒回家去
Shure: If it catches fire, you can take it home.
Jake:但是汽油你可以到换家借
Jake: But you can borrow gasoline from someone.
Shure: 哈哈我操
Shure: Haha, damn.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Tasha: 所以是烤不开是吗
Tasha: So it won't light up, right?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Tasha: 点不着是吗
Tasha: It can't be lit, right?
Shure: 马上找了
Shure: I'll find it right away.
Shure: 酒精马上到了
Shure: The alcohol is coming right up.
Jake:哈哈还特地买了酒精
Jake: Haha, you even bought alcohol.
Shure: 你们可以出来
Shure: You guys can come out.
Shure: 就是布置布置这桌子
Shure: Just set up the table.
Shure: 马上就能吃了
Shure: We'll be able to eat soon.
Shure: 先把饼给你们画圆了
Shure: Let me draw circles on the pancakes first.
Shure: 然后可以布置布置桌子了
Shure: Then we can set up the table.
Shure: 准备准备吃了
Shure: Get ready to eat.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake:至少就是那个几块钱
Jake: At least it's just a few bucks.
Katrina: 去外面是吗
Katrina: Outside, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:半毛半毛新币
Jake: Half a dollar in new currency.
Lucia: 好像是
Lucia: Seems like it.
Jake:5毛新币
Jake: 50 cents in new currency.
Lucia: 不记得了
Lucia: I don't remember.
Shure: 不行我也饿了得赶紧
Shure: No way, I'm hungry too, let's hurry up.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 但是你可以试试看
Lucia: But you can give it a try.
Jake:简单的快乐
Jake: Simple pleasures.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 然后你把蛋糕放在这
Tasha: And then you put the cake here.
Tasha: 然后这样子过去
Tasha: And move it over like this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 好等会你来展示
Tasha: Okay, you can show it later.
Jake:好的交给我吧
Jake: Alright, leave it to me.
Jake:我先切一个土豆试一试
Jake: Let me try cutting a potato first.
Tasha: 如果说你们想要切三层对吧
Tasha: If you want to cut three layers, right?
Tasha: 那那你可能就要在第一层
Tasha: Then you might need to cut the first layer,
Tasha: 第三层和最上面一层
Tasha: the third layer, and the top layer.
Jake:嗯没问题
Jake: No problem.
Tasha: 这样子就可以切出来
Tasha: That's how you can cut it out.
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake:我先试试
Jake: Let me try first.
Tasha: 不是还要加芒果吗
Tasha: Aren't you going to add mangoes too?
Tasha: 然后我们可以一层芒果夹心
Tasha: Then we can have a layer of mango filling.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Tasha: 一层奶油夹心
Tasha: A layer of cream filling.
Katrina: 啊好好吃
Katrina: Ah, it tastes so good.
Tasha: 然后一层草莓夹心等等
Tasha: Then a layer of strawberry filling and so on.
Jake:然后一层
Jake: And then a layer...
Jake:哦好好好
Jake: Oh, okay, okay.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:怎么做啊
Jake: How do we do it?
Jake:那就切草莓
Jake: Then just cut the strawberries.
Jake:切芒果的是吧
Jake: Cutting the mangoes, right?
Tasha: 你不是说尽量把芒果消灭掉吗
Tasha: Didn't you say to try to use up the mangoes?
Jake:就是就是把它切成碎
Jake: Yeah, yeah, just chop them into pieces.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 豆和巧克力豆夹心夹层
Tasha: Bean and chocolate bean fillings.
Tasha: 所以大家要吃什么夹层
Tasha: So, what fillings does everyone want?
Tasha: 就夹什么夹层就行了
Tasha: Just choose whatever filling you like.
Katrina: 天好幸福
Katrina: This is so blissful.
Lucia: 哇哦
Lucia: Wow.
Katrina: 芒果的芒
Katrina: Mango, mango.
Alice:芒果
Alice: Mango.
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: Impressive.
Jake:芒果在这
Jake: The mango is here.
Jake:我要怎么准备它
Jake: How should I prepare it?
Tasha: 把皮削了
Tasha: Peel the skin.
Tasha: 然后你如果想吃大块的你就不切
Tasha: Then if you want big chunks, don't cut it.
Tasha: 就直接一片一片的加进去
Tasha: Just add it slice by slice.
Jake:好我先去拿个酒精
Jake: Okay, I'll get some alcohol first.
Tasha: 如果你想吃芒果丁你就全部都切成丁
Tasha: If you want mango cubes, chop it all into cubes.
Shure: 我还没叫呢
Shure: I haven't called yet.
Alice:你就全部切成
Alice: Just cut it all into...
Jake:好嘞好好好没问题
Jake: Alright, alright, no problem.
Tasha: 敷衍
Tasha: Half-hearted.
Shure: 而且这个不嫌多
Shure: And it won't be too much.
Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, hello.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jake:好来了来了来了嘿
Jake: Okay, coming, coming, hey.
Tasha: 嗯我要吃肉哈哈
Tasha: Mm, I want to eat meat, haha.
Shure: 酱油料酒都得放
Shure: Soy sauce and cooking wine must be added.
Lucia: 那等一下
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Lucia: 他们应该很快就可以考了
Lucia: They should be able to take the test soon.
Shure: 料酒少放
Shure: Use less cooking wine.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm.
Shure: 酱油少那现在就是没有酱油
Shure: Less soy sauce, now we don't have soy sauce.
Shure: 这个事情已经改变不了了
Shure: This can't be changed anymore.
Tasha: 一个蛋糕会不会太少了要不要在烤店
Tasha: One cake might be too little, should we bake more?
Shure: 我怎么能补救一下
Shure: How can I fix this?
Tasha: 纸杯的反正也很简单
Tasha: Cupcakes are really easy anyway.
Shure: 我就多放了点那个烧烤料
Shure: I just added a bit more barbecue seasoning.
Lucia: 都可以你决定
Lucia: It's up to you.
Jake:谢谢您再见
Jake: Thank you, goodbye.
Shure: 然后又稍微就多加了一点蚝油
Shure: And then I added a little more oyster sauce.
Tasha: 所以那天的量是10个的量
Tasha: So that day we made enough for 10.
Tasha: 所以还是考10个就行了
Tasha: So just bake 10, that's enough.
Shure: 呼呼呼呼呼
Shure: Hoo hoo hoo hoo hoo.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈来吧
Jake: Hahaha, come on.
Tasha: 超级简单这个
Tasha: This is super easy.
Shure: 又又买了什么
Shure: What did you buy again?
Shure: 勺子是吗
Shure: A spoon?
Lucia: 也可以如果如果
Lucia: It could be, if...
Shure: 啊对咱没勺
Shure: Oh right, we don't have a spoon.
Lucia: 今天晚上吃不
Lucia: Are we eating it tonight?
Lucia: 完的话
Lucia: If not,
Lucia: 冷藏到明天早上当早饭也可以是吗
Lucia: We can refrigerate it for breakfast tomorrow, right?
Tasha: 可以吧
Tasha: Sure.
Lucia: 好呀
Lucia: Okay.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 早说配勺的话配点酱油不就得了吗
Shure: If you had said we needed a spoon, we could have gotten some soy sauce too.
Lucia: 不会那个什么
Lucia: It won't...
Tasha: 嗯应该可以吧
Tasha: Mm, it should be fine.
Tasha: 那只需要把这个擦干就行了
Tasha: We just need to dry this off.
Shure: 不就把这个问题
Shure: Then this problem...
Shure: 酱油的问题也给解决了吗哈哈哈
Shure: The soy sauce problem would be solved too, hahaha.
Tasha: 然后我们嗯
Tasha: And then we, mm.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 完全看不见他的状态
Tasha: Can't even see his condition.
Shure: 那个夹子去
Shure: The tongs...
Shure: 我怕直接把这个一撒再给它浇灭了
Shure: I'm afraid if I pour it directly, it might put out the fire.
Tasha: 我干错了我挑战一下他
Tasha: I did it wrong, I'll challenge him.
Shure: 哎那个碳夹呢
Shure: Hey, where's the charcoal clamp?
Shure: 我随手
Shure: I just had it.
Jake:当时一直没找着是吧
Jake: Couldn't find it before, right?
Shure: 不是我刚才找着这呢
Shure: No, I just found it here.
Shure: 直接放桌上
Shure: Just put it on the table.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:没关系留点遗憾留个20%
Jake: It's okay, leave a bit of imperfection, about 20%.
Tasha: 他已经
Tasha: He's already...
Lucia: 哦这个太挨着上面了是吗
Lucia: Oh, this is too close to the top, right?
Shure: 这个成功
Shure: This is successful.
Shure: 实验样本放在这边
Shure: The experiment sample is placed here.
Tasha: 对所以哎呀完了有一张纸掉上去了
Tasha: Yeah, so... Oh no, a piece of paper fell on it.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Lucia: 拿筷子剪出来行吗
Lucia: Can we use chopsticks to pick it out?
Tasha: 嗯可以我就感觉他太靠上了
Tasha: Hmm, sure, I just feel it's too close to the top.
Shure: 浇上去
Shure: Pour it over.
Lucia: 哎刚刚用的那根筷子上哪去
Lucia: Hey, where did the chopsticks we just used go?
Tasha: 所以想要挑
Tasha: So I want to pick it.
Lucia: 是不是已经被洗了
Lucia: Have they been washed already?
Lucia: 擦一下
Lucia: Wipe it.
Lucia: 要不要把底下这层撤了
Lucia: Should we remove this bottom layer?
Tasha: 对我刚刚想的也是把它放在
Tasha: Yeah, I was thinking of placing it...
Jake:为啥玩火燎炕
Jake: Why play with fire?
Jake:为为为什么呢
Jake: Why, why, why?
Tasha: 蛋糕雏形
Tasha: Cake prototype.
Shure: 接着这个把这个先点着
Shure: Light this one first.
Tasha: 擦干就行
Tasha: Just wipe it dry.
Shure: 好像点不着他似的你要不
Shure: It doesn't seem to light, how about...
Tasha: 继续准备一下原材料
Tasha: Keep preparing the raw materials.
Katrina: 继续往前走
Katrina: Keep moving forward.
Shure: 要不借着这个你再去
Shure: Or you can use this to go...
Shure: 那个屋里去
Shure: Go inside the room.
Shure: 屋里再烧一下子
Shure: And burn it a bit more inside.
Jake:单细胞生物
Jake: Single-celled organisms.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Tasha: 我去我军手套只有最后一双了不戴了
Tasha: Oh no, I only have one pair of gloves left, forget it.
Alice:别吸了
Alice: Stop inhaling.
Shure: 草履虫只能进行一些简单的生命活动
Shure: Paramecia can only perform simple life activities.
Jake:我来切哦
Jake: I'll cut it.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Alice:圣火来了
Alice: The sacred flame is here.
Shure: 慢慢慢慢来慢慢来
Shure: Slowly, slowly, take it slow.
Shure: 再慢点再慢点再慢点OK
Shure: Even slower, even slower, okay.
Shure: 稳住稳住
Shure: Keep it steady.
Shure: 给他立起来点
Shure: Hold it up a bit.
Katrina: 你最擅长
Katrina: You're the best at this.
Shure: 立起来点
Shure: Hold it up a bit.
Jake:哎是为什么要打奶油是吗
Jake: Hey, why do we need to whip cream?
Katrina: 哎是来
Katrina: Hey, come on.
Katrina: 为什么要打哎
Katrina: Why do we need to whip, hey?
Lucia: 哎这个是还没洗是吧
Lucia: Hey, this hasn't been washed, right?
Katrina: 这个是不是没洗
Katrina: This hasn't been washed, right?
Shure: OK OK好好
Shure: Okay, okay, good.
Katrina: 这个不用洗不用洗
Katrina: This doesn't need to be washed.
Lucia: 这个不用洗不用洗
Lucia: This doesn't need to be washed.
Tasha: 这个不用洗因为他还是放蛋黄
Tasha: This doesn't need to be washed because it still has egg yolk.
Alice:不许来风
Alice: No wind allowed.
Katrina: 因为他还是放弹幕嘛
Katrina: Because it still has bullet comments.
Lucia: 哦行
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Shure: 给他
Shure: Give it to him.
Tasha: 让你打3个蛋你怎
Tasha: Told you to beat three eggs, how come...
Jake:这样好不行啊
Jake: This way is no good.
Lucia: 补充点能量才能打得好
Lucia: Need more energy to beat it well.
Jake:对对对打蛋得费劲呢
Jake: Yeah, yeah, beating eggs is hard work.
Alice:喷点酒精
Alice: Spray some alcohol.
Jake:打了打了
Jake: Beat it, beat it.
Shure: 直接浇灭
Shure: Just put it out.
Alice:牛逼再来吧
Alice: Awesome, do it again.
Tasha: 这呢这呢
Tasha: Here it is, here it is.
Jake:对不起对不起
Jake: Sorry, sorry.
Tasha: 无菌手套不够了不戴了我洗干净
Tasha: We're out of sterile gloves, I washed my hands clean.
Alice:还有没了
Alice: Anymore left?
Katrina: 口红够了
Katrina: Enough lipstick.
Alice:我刚才见了这
Alice: I just saw this...
Shure: 别一会酒精用没了卧槽
Shure: Don't use up all the alcohol, damn.
Lucia: 幸
Lucia: Lucky...
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 好好好好好
Tasha: Good, good, good, good.
Katrina: 好好好
Katrina: Good, good, good.
Lucia: 他盖着盖子
Lucia: He's got the lid on.
Alice:来吧我的板
Alice: Come on, my board.
Alice:这次不许来火了
Alice: No fire this time.
Shure: 你们那边有没有百事可乐
Shure: Do you guys have Pepsi there?
Shure: 有百事可乐
Shure: We have Pepsi.
Shure: 再放点百事
Shure: Add some Pepsi.
Shure: 百事可乐少放一点
Shure: Just a little Pepsi.
Lucia: 哇好厉害啊
Lucia: Wow, that's amazing.
Shure: 鸡翅和这个蚝不要放多了
Shure: Don't add too much chicken wings and oysters.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 蚝放多了甜
Shure: Too many oysters will make it sweet.
Tasha: 打蛋是一门学问你学不来
Tasha: Beating eggs is an art, you can't learn it.
Katrina: 你学不来
Katrina: You can't learn it.
Lucia: 对我学不来哈哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, I can't learn it, haha.
Shure: 放了可乐都
Shure: I've added all the Pepsi.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 我学不来
Tasha: I can't learn it.
Shure: 其他全放了
Shure: Everything else is added.
Shure: 就酱油我以为不用呢
Shure: I thought we didn't need soy sauce.
Tasha: 我替他在说这句话
Tasha: I'm saying this for him.
Alice:圣火降临
Alice: The holy fire descends.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Tasha: the next
Tasha: The next.
Jake:哎我觉得
Jake: Hey, I think...
Lucia: 再再来一个是吧
Lucia: Do one more, right?
Jake:哈哈哈我觉得还有两个赞嘛
Jake: Haha, I think we still have two likes.
Lucia: 我来
Lucia: I'll do it.
Alice:好好好怕爆炸哈哈
Alice: Alright, alright, I'm scared of an explosion, haha.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Lucia: 专注气氛组一万年
Lucia: Focus on the atmosphere group for ten thousand years.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 你这个会磕太厉害了
Lucia: You're too intense with this.
Lucia: 小心哇这都没了哈哈
Lucia: Careful, wow, it's almost gone, haha.
Jake:没问题没问题
Jake: No problem, no problem.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 天选打蛋人
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake:是这是逐步探索边界
Jake: Yes, this is gradually exploring the boundaries.
Alice:你可小心点
Alice: Be careful.
Katrina: 人
Katrina: Man.
Alice:别别顺着你的皮烧着你了
Alice: No, no, you're gonna burn yourself.
Lucia: 他刚才超级强的磕了一下竟然弄没了
Lucia: He just hit it really hard and it disappeared.
Katrina: 我也听到了
Katrina: I heard it too.
Katrina: 我也会烂在手上
Katrina: It could fall apart in my hands.
Tasha: 这个这个这个放到那个冷藏yes
Tasha: This, this, this needs to go in the fridge, yes.
Lucia: 对OK
Lucia: Yeah, OK.
Alice:卧槽太爽了吧这
Alice: Oh my god, this is awesome.
Lucia: 看一眼那可能还是得放到楼上去
Lucia: Take a look, it might still need to go upstairs.
Shure: 帅吧
Shure: Cool, right?
Tasha: 你可以把这个没事你去吧
Tasha: You can handle this, it's fine, you go ahead.
Shure: 此刻已成艺术
Shure: It's become art.
Alice:那那夹子呢
Alice: Where are the tongs?
Lucia: 这个这个放在哪
Lucia: Where does this go?
Lucia: 这已经擦好了
Lucia: It's already clean.
Tasha: 呃干的就放在这就行我觉得
Tasha: Uh, just put the dry ones here, I think.
Alice:你夹子去哪了
Alice: Where did the tongs go?
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Got it.
Jake:哎真好看
Jake: Wow, looks nice.
Shure: BB着了这不可能
Shure: BB's on fire, no way.
Shure: 不着了吧这
Shure: It's not burning, right?
Alice:你夹子呢
Alice: Where are the tongs?
Tasha: 这个擦一下这个
Tasha: Wipe this, please.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Alice:那夹子
Alice: The tongs.
Jake:谁
Jake: Who?
Shure: 那夹子我刚才随地扔到
Shure: I just threw the tongs somewhere.
Jake:这个好
Jake: This is good.
Alice:哦我知道了
Alice: Oh, I see it.
Jake:哇起火了
Jake: Wow, it's on fire.
Jake:哇好开心
Jake: Wow, so happy.
Jake:看一眼烤一烤
Jake: Take a look, roast it a bit.
Shure: 看到了吗
Shure: Did you see it?
Lucia: 没问题没问题
Lucia: No problem, no problem.
Tasha: 他怎么洗着洗着碗跑了呢
Tasha: How did he run off while washing the dishes?
Lucia: 呃那是要洗啥呀我来
Lucia: Uh, what needs to be washed? I'll do it.
Tasha: 这个洗干擦干就行
Tasha: Just wash and dry this, and it'll be fine.
Katrina: which are reconnecting
Lucia: 洗
Lucia: Wash.
Tasha: 哇那我们可以开始吃了
Tasha: Wow, we can start eating now.
Lucia: 这不能用吧
Lucia: This can't be used, right?
Tasha: 哎他回来了哈哈
Tasha: Oh, he's back, haha.
Tasha: 交给您
Tasha: Here you go.
Tasha: 您来
Tasha: You do it.
Tasha: 您愿意
Tasha: If you want.
Shure: 找一个够长的
Shure: Find one that's long enough.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 你来把它搅拌
Tasha: You stir it.
Tasha: 给你你从此学会烘焙
Tasha: Here you go, you'll learn baking from now on.
Tasha: 筷子帮您准备好了
Tasha: The chopsticks are ready for you.
Tasha: 完了就这样吧
Tasha: Okay, let's just do it this way.
Tasha: 开始把它充分搅拌
Tasha: Start stirring it thoroughly.
Tasha: 搅拌到完全融合
Tasha: Stir until it's fully blended.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 真的可以
Tasha: It really works.
Lucia: 真的可以
Lucia: It really works.
Tasha: 这是真的可以
Tasha: This really works.
Lucia: 至少肉眼上完全了
Lucia: At least it looks good to the naked eye.
Lucia: 就至少肉眼上可以
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Okay
Tasha: 40克
Tasha: 40 grams
Lucia: 40克
Lucia: 40 grams
Tasha: 这用的太快了补个货
Tasha: We're using this up too fast, let's restock
Katrina: 他们心应该是都着了
Katrina: Their hearts must be burning
Tasha: 面粉哪都有
Tasha: Flour is everywhere
Shure: 累死了妈妈
Shure: I'm exhausted, mom
Shure: 嘻嘻
Shure: Hehe
Lucia: 嗯又灭了吗
Lucia: Hmm, did it go out again?
Shure: 就是不大信
Shure: I just don't quite believe it
Lucia: 他们又灭了
Lucia: They put it out again
Lucia: 咱今天晚上能吃上饭不
Lucia: Will we get to eat dinner tonight?
Shure: 能哎呦
Shure: Yes, we will. Ouch
Lucia: 哎呦吓我一跳
Lucia: Oh, you scared me
Alice:那个酒精呢
Alice: Where's the alcohol?
Tasha: 哎呦哈哈
Tasha: Oh, haha
Shure: 吓我一跳
Shure: You scared me
Lucia: 哈哈哈行
Lucia: Hahaha, okay
Shure: 不要质疑我
Shure: Don't doubt me
Lucia: 有您这句话我就放心了
Lucia: With your words, I'm relieved
Alice:还有一点点火
Alice: There's still a little flame
Tasha: 有您这句话我就放心了
Tasha: With your words, I'm relieved
Alice:不知道能给它弄着不
Alice: Not sure if we can get it going
Shure: 咱保底不是还有外卖吗
Shure: Worst case, we still have takeout
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Shure: 不行这些就拿
Shure: If not, just
Shure: 锅一炒
Shure: Stir-fry it
Tasha: 我已经做了第二种甜品了
Tasha: I've already made a second dessert
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: It's okay, it's okay
Shure: 剩下这些不行
Shure: The rest won't work
Lucia: backup plan
Lucia: Backup plan
Katrina: 我要吃一块披萨
Katrina: I want to eat a slice of pizza
Shure: 还可以炒
Shure: We can still stir-fry
Tasha: 您OK了吧
Tasha: Are you okay now?
Tasha: OK了OK了
Tasha: Okay, okay
Jake:还不行
Jake: Not yet
Tasha: 啊嗯
Tasha: Ah, hmm
Lucia: 好了好了好了
Lucia: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 我们可以这样
Shure: We can do it like this.
Tasha: 来吧放在这里这里
Tasha: Come on, put it here, here.
Alice:会有点危险
Alice: It might be a bit dangerous.
Lucia: 放在哪里
Lucia: Where should we put it?
Lucia: 这里
Lucia: Here.
Tasha: 然后继续搅
Tasha: Then keep stirring.
Tasha: 对对不我说等会继续搅
Tasha: Yes, yes, no, I mean wait, then keep stirring.
Tasha: 是不是应该换个大点
Tasha: Should we use a bigger one?
Jake:这个是要做什么
Jake: What is this for?
Tasha: 这个这个就做第2种甜品
Tasha: This, this is for making the second dessert.
Alice:这上面我有一点点纠结
Alice: I'm a bit confused about this.
Tasha: 就纸杯蛋糕呀
Tasha: It's just a cupcake.
Tasha: 可以爆浆
Tasha: It can be filled.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:笑死
Alice: That's hilarious.
Lucia: 听起来就好好吃哦
Lucia: It sounds so delicious.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Alright.
Jake:就这个纸杯吗
Jake: Just this cupcake?
Alice:送入烤箱
Alice: Put it in the oven.
Lucia: 对就咱们那天做的那种
Lucia: Yeah, like the ones we made that day.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Tasha: 但是再升升升升级也可以
Tasha: But we can upgrade it a bit.
Shure: 不行我就把这个轱辘一直放在地下烧
Shure: No way, I'll just keep this wheel burning on the ground.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:给他弄灭了吧
Alice: Put it out for him.
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 开始搅拌
Lucia: Start stirring.
Tasha: 搅拌到看不到面粉就行
Tasha: Stir until you can't see the flour.
Tasha: 甜点大师诞生了
Tasha: A dessert master is born!
Shure: 然后再浇点酒精上面
Shure: Then pour some alcohol on top.
Shure: 奶奶个腿的
Shure: Damn it.
Tasha: 两位两位后厨人员配一位大师
Tasha: Two kitchen staff for one master.
Lucia: 哈哈大师
Lucia: Haha, a master.
Lucia: 等一下啊好吧
Lucia: Wait a second, okay?
Lucia: 我怎么给他擦的和成面了都哈哈哈
Lucia: Why did I wipe it so much that it's all dough now, hahaha.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Tasha: OK我们可以把蛋清那个啊
Tasha: Okay, we can separate the egg whites.
Tasha: 对对可以下一步
Tasha: Yes, yes, we can proceed to the next step.
Tasha: 哇哇有种大厨的感觉
Tasha: Wow, feels like a real chef.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina: 好搞笑啊
Katrina: So funny.
Katrina: 特别是他在那打仗
Katrina: Especially him fighting over there.
Tasha: 糖35克
Tasha: 35 grams of sugar.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Tasha: 糖35克玉米淀粉10克
Tasha: 35 grams of sugar, 10 grams of cornstarch.
Tasha: 你要来打发
Tasha: Do you want to whip it?
Tasha: 打发吗
Tasha: Whip it?
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Sure.
Tasha: 可以哎把那个头拿来就行对
Tasha: Yeah, just bring the head over here, that's all.
Lucia: 呃安上是吧好嘞
Lucia: Uh, put it on, right? Got it.
Tasha: 安上之后先挤点柠檬汁进去
Tasha: After putting it on, squeeze some lemon juice in.
Tasha: 然后再开始打
Tasha: Then start whipping.
Alice:烧点硬盘
Alice: Burn some hard drive.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Shure: 这不行这不行
Shure: This isn't working.
Tasha: 啊哦
Tasha: Uh oh.
Tasha: 哦你们在这
Tasha: Oh, you guys are here.
Tasha: 我刚没有看到
Tasha: I didn't see you.
Tasha: 怎么办挤了一颗种子进去
Tasha: What to do? A seed got in.
Tasha: 我直接用手拿他
Tasha: I'll just pick it out with my hand.
Tasha: 他怎么这么不听话
Tasha: Why is it so disobedient?
Tasha: 我靠哈哈哈
Tasha: Gosh, hahaha.
Shure: 嗯这烧透了
Shure: Yeah, this is burned through.
Shure: 还是这书就是刚才
Shure: Still, this book just...
Tasha: 怎么个角度法呢
Tasha: What kind of angle?
Shure: 原来那本来就烧起来的
Shure: It was already burning.
Tasha: 不多来
Tasha: Not much more to go.
Tasha: 放进来继续搅
Tasha: Put it in and keep stirring.
Lucia: 然后现在可以打了吗还是啥
Lucia: So, can we start whipping now or what?
Tasha: 呃对打
Tasha: Uh, yeah, whip it.
Lucia: 我是要把这个头先放进去
Lucia: Should I put the head in first?
Lucia: 然后把它调到
Lucia: And then set it to...
Tasha: 对对对对对对对对对对
Tasha: Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 直接调到五
Lucia: Set it directly to five.
Katrina: 今天是发现内空线爆
Katrina: Today, the inner line exploded.
Tasha: 来吧继续抽
Tasha: Come on, keep whipping.
Shure: 人生没有容易2字懂了吗
Shure: Life isn't easy, understand?
Tasha: 哎用这个抽就可以了啊
Tasha: Hey, you can just use this to draw.
Tasha: 好吧你用这个抽也可以
Tasha: Okay, you can use this to draw too.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 呃可以
Tasha: Uh, okay.
Shure: 这时候现在知道谁知盘中餐
Shure: Now you know who's aware of the food on their plate.
Shure: 粒粒皆辛苦了吧
Shure: Every grain is hard work, right?
Tasha: 好对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 可以了
Lucia: That's enough.
Tasha: 可以了然后然后加糖
Tasha: That's enough, then add sugar.
Katrina: 此时拍有温度
Katrina: It looks warm right now.
Tasha: 就是糖分三次加
Tasha: You add sugar in three stages.
Tasha: 你看第一次就这种
Tasha: You see, for the first time, it's like this.
Lucia: 你看
Lucia: Look.
Tasha: 有这种粗粗的气孔的时候加
Tasha: When there are these big bubbles, add it.
Tasha: 然后呢打到那种没有粗粗的气孔
Tasha: Then, beat it until there are no big bubbles.
Tasha: 打到绵密的气孔的时候加第二次
Tasha: Beat it until the bubbles are fine, then add the second time.
Lucia: 绵密的气孔
Lucia: Fine bubbles.
Shure: 妈妈说你快远离这个是非之地
Shure: Mom says you better stay away from this place of trouble.
Alice:你就搁那别动就行
Alice: Just leave it there, don't move it.
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Ah, right.
Lucia: 这样看起来还可以
Lucia: It looks okay this way.
Tasha: 这就是绵密气孔
Tasha: These are the fine bubbles.
Shure: sorry吧你
Shure: Sorry, you.
Tasha: 然后再加第二
Tasha: Then add the second time.
Tasha: 第二次烫可以多加一点
Tasha: The second time, you can add more sugar.
Tasha: 让他帮助他定型
Tasha: It helps to shape it.
Tasha: 然后还剩一点点就是最后成型
Tasha: Then there's just a little left for the final shaping.
Shure: 这个丁烷还是丙烷
Shure: Is this butane or propane?
Lucia: 这个这次要打到大概什么样呃打到
Lucia: This time, how much should we beat it, uh, beat it until...
Tasha: 呃打到
Tasha: Uh, beat it until...
Tasha: 你看着打吧
Tasha: Just beat it until you think it's right.
Lucia: 啊哈哈就是
Lucia: Ahaha, just...
Shure: 天然气好像会高一点
Shure: Natural gas seems to be higher.
Lucia: what
Lucia: What?
Tasha: 哇哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Tasha: 就是一个在搅一个在搅
Tasha: One person stirs, another person stirs.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina: 不要你喽
Katrina: No way!
Tasha: 差不多吧
Tasha: Almost there
Katrina: 嗨
Katrina: Hey
Tasha: 然后加最后一次
Tasha: And then one last time
Tasha: 最后一次就是要他提起来
Tasha: The last time he needs to lift it up
Katrina: 喂
Katrina: Hey
Tasha: 就你看他就倒了
Tasha: Just look, he fell
Tasha: 要提起来
Tasha: Lift it up
Tasha: 不倒就行了嗯
Tasha: As long as it doesn't fall, it's fine
Tasha: 好了你这边没什么问题了
Tasha: Alright, no problems on your side
Katrina: 我不能看到什么
Katrina: I can't see anything
Tasha: 然后等他哈哈哈
Tasha: And then wait for him, hahaha
Katrina: 给你看我们在干嘛
Katrina: Let me show you what we're doing
Katrina: 我们在点火
Katrina: We're lighting a fire
Lucia: 嗯哈哈还可以助威吗
Lucia: Hmm, can we cheer?
Alice:妈这样显得我像个小丑
Alice: Mom, it makes me look like a clown
Katrina: 因为我们要烤肉吃
Katrina: Because we're going to barbecue
Katrina: 但是我们的火一直没起来
Katrina: But our fire just won't start
Alice:我觉得可以上烤盘了
Alice: I think it's ready for the grill
Alice:好就这样吧
Alice: Alright, let's do it
Tasha: 稳定了吗
Tasha: Is it stable?
Katrina: 他们在做甜品
Katrina: They're making desserts
Lucia: 刚才好像还不太行
Lucia: It didn't seem to work earlier
Tasha: 差不多差不多嘛
Tasha: It's almost there, almost
Lucia: 还是这样搅
Lucia: Keep stirring it
Tasha: 嗯你加5克玉米淀粉进去
Tasha: Yeah, add 5 grams of cornstarch
Alice:上吧上吧
Alice: Go ahead, go ahead
Alice:哎呀我来
Alice: Oh, let me do it
Tasha: 他就会成定的更快一点
Tasha: It'll set faster that way
Shure: 不行就多烤会呗
Shure: If it doesn't work, just roast it longer
Shure: 咱慢慢熏
Shure: Let's smoke it slowly
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Katrina: 这是做的蛋糕
Katrina: This is a cake.
Tasha: 差不多 可以
Tasha: 嗯可以
Tasha: Hmm, alright.
Tasha: 你你你这样子
Tasha: You, you, you, like this.
Katrina: 这我们买的东西
Katrina: These are the things we bought.
Tasha: 你其实这样子
Tasha: You actually like this.
Tasha: 就是空白的地方
Tasha: There's an empty spot here.
Shure: 这一点没着的
Shure: This part isn't burning.
Tasha: 他就转出来了
Tasha: He just spun it out.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 哦哈哈
Tasha: Oh, haha.
Alice:其实我觉得可以放上去
Alice: Actually, I think we can put it on.
Katrina: 我们不用干活
Katrina: We don't need to work.
Alice:你试一下这个温度
Alice: Try this temperature.
Lucia: 原来如此
Lucia: I see.
Katrina: 天午饭
Katrina: Sky lunch.
Tasha: 对洗掉
Tasha: Yeah, wash it off.
Shure: 是的是的肯定有用
Shure: Yes, yes, it will definitely work.
Katrina: 去公园去买烤肉
Katrina: Let's go to the park and get some BBQ.
Tasha: 对他洗掉之后还有用
Tasha: Yeah, it will still work after washing it off.
Katrina: 排骨没了
Katrina: The ribs are gone.
Lucia: 就是打发奶油要用
Lucia: We need it to whip the cream.
Tasha: 就是打发奶油要用
Tasha: We need it to whip the cream.
Lucia: 哦好的
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 所以打奶油一会要用吧
Tasha: 嗯等蛋糕胚烤好再打
Tasha: Hmm, wait until the cake base is baked, then whip.
Katrina: 这是做纸杯蛋糕吗
Katrina: Are these for making cupcakes?
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Tasha: 嗯做两种蛋糕
Tasha: Hmm, making two kinds of cakes.
Shure: 啊也是
Shure: Ah, that's true.
Tasha: 因为感嗯太闲了
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Tasha: 感觉外面
Tasha: Feels like outside...
Alice:你去准备那啥吧我扇会
Alice: You go prepare that, I'll fan it.
Katrina: 外面的火还没起来呢
Katrina: The fire outside hasn't started yet.
Tasha: 还没起来
Tasha: It hasn't started yet.
Katrina: 他那个炭烧不着
Katrina: His charcoal won't light up.